today we're going to talk about soil
and you've probably noticed that there
are many different kinds of soils the
soil near a beach looks and feels very
different than the soil in a forest
and part of the reason for that
difference is something called soil
texture
soil texture
so when soil is formed different types
of rock breakdown because of the wind
and the rain and the weather
and they become differently sized
particles
and the combination of these differently
sized particles creates soil texture
so these differently sized particles can
be broken down into three groups
we have
sand
we have
we have silt
and we have clay
sand is made up of the larger and
heavier particles of soil sand is around
two millimeters
two millimeters to zero
0.05 millimeters
which is a 20th of a millimeter in
diameter
and if it feels very gritty to touch
clay on the other hand is the smallest
particles of soil it's around
0.002 millimeters and smaller that's a
500th of a millimeter so really tiny
if you rubbed clay between your fingers
it would feel smooth and you wouldn't be
able to feel the individual particles of
soil
and unlike sand you can't even see
clay's particles with a naked eye
most people are familiar with sandy
soils and clayey soils but silt is right
in between it's made up of particles
between the sizes of clay and sand
so it's between
0.05 millimeters
and
0.002 millimeters
so when you think of silts imagine
baking flour it's powdery
powdery
and it can be carried easily by wind and
water
but soil is more complicated than just
these three soil types
if you grabbed a handful of soil from
outside your home it would probably be a
combination of all three soil types
along with some organic material a
soil's unique texture that is its
combination of silt sand and clay
affects how plants will grow and so
gardeners often want to know about their
soil texture so they know what kinds of
plants to grow in that area this is
where a helpful diagram called the soil
texture triangle comes in
the soil texture triangle
the triangle allows us to place any soil
sample into one of 12 different soil
texture categories the 12 different
categories are broken up based on the
percentage of silt clay and sand in the
soil to see how this works let's do an
example
let's say a gardener determined that our
soil was 30 sand
40 salt
and 30 clay
so how can we figure out what kind of
soil we have
first we need to pick a side of the
triangle to start with
i'll start with sand we know we have 30
sand
so we go along the side of the triangle
until we find the 30 mark right here
we want to draw a line from this point
to the side of the triangle that this
arrow is pointing to
the arrow is pointing towards the clay
side
so we draw the line from the 30 sand
mark
through the triangle to the clay side
like this
and by drawing this line we already know
that our soil sample will fall into a
category along this line
so it could be sil sloam loam clay loam
or clay but to figure out exactly where
it is let's draw another line
let's do silt the soil has 40 silt
we'll draw our line through the triangle
towards the sand side because of this
arrow
so again we do the same thing we go
along the percent silts line
we find the 40 mark and we're going to
draw a line from 40 percent to the other
side of the triangle
and you can see when we draw that line
these two lines intersect at the clay
loam point
but to double check let's draw a line
from
the 30 clay mark
to
the other side of the triangle like this
as you can see these three lines all
intersected at the same point right here
in clay loam
so we know that we have clay loam
notice that the percentage of clay silts
and sand all add up to a total of 100
we could have picked any two of these
lines just two to find our answer we
don't need to draw three lines every
time let's do another example
let's say our gardener has another plot
with soil that contains 58 sand
27 silts
and 15 clay
so i'm going to go along the percent
sand part and find 58 so that's pretty
close to 60. i'm going to draw a line
from 58 percent to the other side of the
triangle
sometimes the example question doesn't
give us round numbers to work with so
when that's the case i like to use a
ruler or a straight edge just to make
sure that my lines are in the correct
spot
next i'm going to use the 15 clay so i
find the 15 clay mark
and we draw a line from 50 15 to the
other side of the triangle following the
direction of the lines within the
triangle
and we can see that our two lines
intersect at this point
so we have sandy loam
the gardener has these two plots clay
loam
and sandy loam
so when the gardener looks at her two
plots she might want to take into
account the different kinds of soil
certain kinds of plants do better in
clay loam soil while others would do
better in the sandy loam soil
this is partly because clayey soils hold
onto moisture for longer than sandy
soils do so the plants in the gardener's
sandy loam plot would do better if they
had longer root systems to access water
deeper in the ground or if they stored
water inside themselves to access later
the gardener could use a gardening book
or the internet to see what kinds of
plants would do best in each of her two
plots thanks for watching and happy soil
identification